[Music]
we'll say we've said it over and over
and over for the past three or four
weeks but um
it bears saying a lot more as a matter
of fact i think we're going to do an
event on this coming up we'll let y'all
know when and everything but real
estate's such a hot topic right now
there's so many things going on with it
but i am positive
okay
that real estate is not going to go down
in value in the next five years
some of you are going oh it's
artificially high it's going to go down
no it's not there's so much talk of the
crash right now there is not it's it's
simply not going to go down and let me
help you with this okay i've been doing
real estate for 30 years
it's a real simple equation
100 percent
and i just taped the thing a few minutes
ago for the instagram goobies out there
with my with brooke who runs instagram
stuff but 100 of real estate prices is
based on supply demand
period when there is more buyers than
sellers prices go up
when there is more sellers than buyers
prices go down now there's things that
affect how many buyers there are and how
many sellers there are but that's the
equation
you know inflation recession
stagflation idiots in the white house
high interest rates
affect the number of buyers
but unless the number of buyers goes
substantially below
the number of sellers
in the marketplace
you're not going to see prices go down
and we know that this is not going to
happen because it this year we have 128
million households in 2007 we had 116
million households 12 million more
households today that need houses in
2007 there were 2.1
million new housing starts
this year 1.4 million
the inventory available for sale of
houses right now is 50 of what it was in
2007.
supply is drastically
short
versus demand
prices are not going down there is not
going to be a real estate crash there's
nothing in this equation that says
there's going to be a real estate crash
nothing
and you take it to the bank i've told
you some other stuff that came true like
i told you inflation was coming i tell
you stuff guys i've been doing this a
long time
i'm gonna wait on the house prices to go
down you're they're not going down
what goes up must go down you're wrong